This is a new and secret ranking factor
that helps your website show up in AI
search mode on Google and it's called
the preferred sources and no one is
talking about how powerful this is. In a
latest update from Google, users can now
customize their top stories with
preferred sources. They can head over to
stories and they can add your website or
their favorite website as a preferred
source. Now this is going to be a direct
ranking signal and a direct signal to
Google that people like this source so
it will show that source more and more
to that user and also to other users as
well because users love the content and
Google loves to show users what they
love. So this is how you can get more
preferred sources and rank higher in AI
search mode and get cited more often by
AI. We created a specific solution to
this problem right in Word Rocket. It's
called our trending news playbook and
essentially how it works is it allows
you to enter in target keywords or
tracked keywords that people are talking
about on Google News articles. So you
first enter in the keyword that's
related to your niche. So for example,
let's say you're in the stock market so
we can do stocks, we can do AI
stocks,
stock market update today. Right? So we
can enter in any search query that's
related to our specific niche. We can
choose our region and we can choose how
fresh we want the topics to be. So for
something like stocks, you want
something to be very very fresh which is
24 hours. We're not just scraping, you
know, any AI to get this information.
We're actually scraping Google News and
we're using Google Trends to see what is
popular, what is trending or where's
content gap opportunities that you can
find to write on that no one else is
writing on. So we're going to name our
automation so stocks automation.
Stock market updates is going to be our
niche or topic area. We're then going to
select how often we want to create
content around this. I choose one per
day. I think you could you should start
with that. You can choose your brand
voice. You can choose your research
model. You can choose how many images
you want. So, everything you can do in
Word Rocket, you can set it up geo
optimization, internal links, and so on.
Then we can go to next and we can
schedule this in as a post or as a draft
onto our WordPress site. We select our
site and then we create We're then going
to find a trending topic based on
today's data, based upon what is new,
what is trending, and based upon what
people are talking about that's relevant
to your specific niche. So, give it a
couple of minutes and we'll get a topic
that we can start writing on. We get the
first topic here. So, the stock market
today, June 9th, 2026. That is today.
Uh Dow rises, Space X and OpenAI IPOs in
focus, uh June 9th, 2023. And we see why
this topic makes sense, right? And why
it is a perfect uh topic to write about.
So, now I can go ahead and click view
and we can see that the content will
start generating. Here's some of the
other trending news automations that
we've created specifically within the
mortgage niche. So, we can see here that
we found topics about the Bank of Canada
interest rate decision hold in uh June.
So, we can see that this is again
timely, up-to-date information. Canada
spring economic update 2026, new federal
infrastructure agenda, Canada's job
market surges in May 2026. So, if you
take a look at any of these articles,
first of all, beautiful images, last
updated yesterday, quick answers, geo
optimized, key takeaways, geo optimized.
We see the internal um sorry, the
in-text citations here. Another
beautiful image, right? None of this
screams AI slop. Like, we actually take
the time to do research, to write the
content with in-text citations that geo
optimize. And this is the content that
will get cited by AI search, right? We
see the references is here. So, we know
our content is citation-backed and it
actually has live and up-to-date
information. So, spring economic update,
it's pulling from
very reputable site, taking that
information, and using that within the
article, and then also following GEO
insights to add other questions that
people may be asking so that this
article, when someone searches up, you
know, what is Canada's spring economic
update, that this article is going to be
cited because it has all of the
information that's needed, but most
importantly, it has the fan out
questions as well included. Again, if I
go back over to our automations, and if
I go over to mortgages, if you take a
look at the latest article, so Bank of
Canada interest rate decision, high cold
or cut this June, again, beautiful
image, quick answer, updated today,
another image here,
GEO optimized.
We can see our
our research has been done. We can see
another perfect image there.
And then we get our FAQs, our
references, our title and meta
description. And you can set this up so
that this will post directly over to
your website as well. So, you wouldn't
have to actually do any heavy lifting
every single day. Your website will be
in the cutting edge of news within your
nation. And that is what's going to get
you cited in AI search, and that is
what's going to get you to become more
of a preferred source by users. I hope
that you guys enjoyed today's video. If
you want to try out the trending news
playbook, just head over to
app.wordrocket.ai and sign up for a free
account. If you haven't to try out Word
Rocket or upgrade to use this feature.
I'll see you in the next one. You take
care.